in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for September 24th, on which we commemorate our righteous
Father, Silwan, the Athenite.
This new star in the firmament of the Church was the Son of a poor peasant family in the
province of Tambov in Russia.
From his earliest years he said to himself, when I grow up, I shall go all over the world
looking for God.
Tales of the ascetics and saints set his heart ablaze with love for God.
And with this thought, always in his mind, he was drawn to the monastic life.
But little by little, he lost his childhood fervor and having great physical strength
and a warm and open nature, he led the same worldly life as the other peasants, with
the result that one day in the course of a scuffle, he almost killed his antagonist.
This incident helped to bring him to himself.
A few days later, while he was asleep, he saw a snake crawl down his throat and heard
the voice of the most holy Mother of God, saying to him with unutterable gentleness, just
as you found it loathsome, to swallow a snake, so I find your ways ugly to look upon.
He was deeply affected by this revelation that completely changed his outlook on life.
Next by ardent repentance, he now thought only of mount Athos and the last judgment.
In the year 1892, on completing his military service, he set out for the holy mountain and
became a novice in the great Russian monastery of St. Pantelemon, which was then at the height
of its prosperity, with almost 2,000 monks.
The young novice was overjoyed on being told at the end of his general confession that
all his previous sins were forgiven, and, forgetful of his deep repentance, immediately fell
prey to carnal thoughts.
Unused as he was to the art of struggling against thoughts, he was sorely put to the test,
and tempted to return to the world.
His confessor recommended him never more to linger on bad thoughts and to drive them away
by the Jesus Prayer as soon as they took shape in his mind.
During the 45 years of his monastic life, the servant of God never again harbored any evil
thought, and, having ever in mind the love of the Lord and the gentleness of the Holy Spirit,
he never lost his temper.
His introduction to the spiritual life came not from any theoretical teaching, but through
following the established pattern of monastic life.
The Jesus Prayer was with him continuously, during the day as he promptly fulfilled his
obedience, in complete renunciation of his own will, and above all, during the night which
he eventually gave over entirely to the prayer, snatching no more than one or two hours of sleep.
He had been at the monastery only three weeks when the prayer entered his heart, as he was
praying before the icon of the Mother of God, and began from then on to flow forth continuously
by itself.
This grace which God sometimes grants to beginners was followed by a relentless combat with the thoughts
suggested by the devils who would sometimes try to persuade him he was a saint, and sometimes
provoke him to despair of the mercy of God.
One night a strange light filled his cell, even piercing his body, but, observing that
contrition had gone from his prayer, he knew that he was in the grip of a satanic illusion.
The months passed until there came a day when he reached the final stages of desperation
and sat for a long while on his bed, completely distraught.
During Vespers that day as he uttered the prayer, Lord Jesus Christ have mercy upon me the sinner.
Looking at the icon of Christ, he was all of a sudden overwhelmed by a boundless light,
but this time gentle and peaceful and beheld the living Christ who looked at him gently and
with joy, flooding his whole being with the love that transported his spirit into a contemplation
of God beyond all representation.
He said later that it was in the Holy Spirit that he had known without any doubt that it
was the Lord Jesus Christ himself who had appeared to him and made his grace known to him
in its perfection.
When the vision disappeared, his soul had become a thirst with so great a love for God that
night and day his spirit inconsolably sought the beloved, crying, My soul yearns after
the O Lord, and I seek thee with tears.
Hadst thou O Lord not drawn me by thy grace, I could not thus yearn after thee and seek thee
with tears.
Thou has given unto me to live by thy Holy Spirit, and my soul have loved thee.
Given his desire to pray without ceasing, he was permitted to go to live at Old Rosicone,
a dependency of the monastery inhabited at that time by rigorous ascetics, but he caught
a cold there, and for the rest of his life suffered from headaches that he considered to
be a punishment for a proposal that he came to regard as disobedience.
One year later, he was called back to the monastery to take on the work of steward.
He was responsible for more than 200 workmen, but he did not at all moderate his ascetic life.
Every morning he went to the workshops to distribute the day's work, and then went back to
his cell to pray with tears for the men, for their families, and for the whole world.
His ardent prayer was constantly troubled by the attacks of devils, putting proud thoughts
before him.
He fought this fight for fifteen years, consoled sometimes by the visualization of grace, and
all the more distraught when it withdrew and the demons resumed their attacks.
During one of these nights, when a devil appeared in front of the icon of Christ, waiting to
be worshipped, Silwan asked for the Lord's aid, and Christ said to him, the proud always
suffer from devils.
"'Lord,' said Silwan, "'teach me what I must do that my soul may become humble.
Keep thy mind in hell and despair not,' the Lord answered him.
With this word, God revealed to him that all ascetic striving must be directed towards acquiring
humility of Christ who has said, learn of me, for I am meek and lowly in heart, and that
this humility is the royal road leading to pure prayer and dispassion.
From that time the grace of God dwelt constantly in Silwan, bringing him peace and an unchallenged
mastery over all the movements of his soul.
He said that as soon as he let his mind leave the fire of hell, the thoughts immediately
regained their strength.
With this gift of divine humility, Christ filled his heart with an inexpressible love for all
men, for the whole Adam, and it was with fiery tears that he prayed for everyone, especially
for the dead, and taught that the final criterion of knowledge of the truth is love for enemies.
He said on this matter to pray for people is to shed blood.
This humble, after-night monk who lived his whole life in self-effacement and the martyrdom
of prayer for the world, has, like a new prophet, bequeathed to the church a compendium of the
entire Christian message and the sure path to reach perfection.
He spent the rest of his life in this manner, upholding the world by his prayer, and begging
the Lord that all men might know him by the grace of his Holy Spirit.
When finished his course here below, he fell asleep in peace on the 24th or 11th of September
in the year 1938.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.